yo what up reject Nation we have made it to
episode 4 I am so excited I've heard this is
a good one really I don't know I was just making
stuff up been in the same room with you the past
few hours I haven't heard anything CG take your
mask off why because it's Mass grade ohone was
like you know I wish I could intro the video so
I can make my Mas that's true every time I come
here I just beg you to intro of the videos and you
don't let me guys guys guys um and gals and gals
don't want to exclude the gals leave a like on
this video that would be great who's your favorite
gal of all time tele friend to tell friend
subscribe and click that Bell to get notify want a
reaction for five is up here on this very Channel
you haven't seen our other reactions this one
they're of course here I hope you like the reviews
because that's where most of our thoughts go into
it yeah that makes sense yes yes yes yes Greg
let's go wo uh someone edited this video thank
you full length Reaction watch along where you see
with your own copy of hasb been Hotel available
for super sex Rejects at our patreon page cover
several things super there H watch s all right
Roxy Do It Rocky name things that rhyme with four
back and forth go four Thor score more poor core
door lore sure roar I did that one already
you said Roar yeah I said Roar that doesn't
count whoa what is going on finally awake angel
dust yeah and what's it to you maybe this is a
that she filmed or he filmed maybe yeah fine I
guess I'll just have to St the information out
of here yeah yeah yeah do your worst daddy daddy
this performance want me a sex SE sexy one it's uh
very honest that is a word for it authentic you
know not a very convincing interrogation scene
oh are we going to get to know him this episode
you really going to sit there and act like these
scripts ain't hot garbage this is classy art I
know everything about you and these mother at
this point that one is an insecure buffoon whose
lonely ass watches you idiot sleep o read them for
f princess is a bleeding heart who wants to solve
everybody else's problem except her own oh my God
he's the most film The War of them all this one
judges everyone and everything because she hates
herself this a great deconstruction and Nifty yeah
you don't even want to know what her do I kind of
do I really do and you don't get me started I see
right through you and all this [__] L out I'll
fake you all wow I had no idea guess that's why
I'm an actor dumbass yeah that's me no no I just I
no I no looks like B needs me for an uh emergency
shoot mhm sure you know what I don't give a [__]
what some drunk ass bartender thinks of me I
think you do I'm sure you'll manage without me
there isn't much time left for the hotel to prove
itself what unique characters what am I doing
right wrong well I mean you're the princess of
hell so you don't really use the power that comes
with that which I love about you I don't know
command a little more Authority but that's so
mean respect my authority that's so mean I could
be so aggressively kind to Angel's boss she's so
Amy po to me man convince him to let Angel spend
more time in the hotel oh no she's going to get
Angel fired oh Oh Daddy I do you really expect
me to memorize this whole script just improv
it do you think anyone watches for the dialogue a
what an insult I guess I'll have to do all of you
who this is adult animation uh my name's Rocky
no one gives you [__] oh so this is where the
magic what in the ever loving are you doing I'm
here to get you some time off for the hotel now
where's your boss oh you are going nowhere
in the angel what is the hold up uhoh I'm
coming not off camera you're not abusive
ass relationship what can I do for such
a you don't want to roll do you because I could
make you a star make us both richer than well
you're pap no richer than the devil well let's
take this [__] from the top action I sure hope
you don't hurt me with those don't move you
spicy little uh sleeve F sleep oh my God I'm
sorry I was just telling him about the hman
hotel not at all princess it doesn't bother
me one no no going to get hurt if you want
help with the script Maybe I can pitch some
scenarios that are more oh no okay okay oh what
have you done you're ruining a perfectly good
film whoa that was pretty cool yeah I I can
clean this up I I can don't you worry your
pretty blonde head about it we have people
for that can I see you in your dressing room
for a moment oh no is he going to get beat I was
thinking about that F I didn't know damn it you
really think you can have Lucifer's little [__]
fight your battles for you this is horrifying you
know she can't do anything I own you or have you
forgotten that oh I see I see when I say you are
20 guys before lunch you say yes Valentino this
is disturbing you better get that out of my St
Studio look Val this is absolutely horrifying
wow now you're going to go get rid of her and
then you're filming all night get me I mean we
are in hell I know no it's actually feeling like
evil yeah and I have been waiting for it to like
feel like truly evil people get your asses back
on set and we are taking this from the top what
makes you think you can treat him like oh just
stop Angel what are you talking Charlie leave
oh no you made think worse I just wanted to
help you you actually want to help me get out
of here a no I didn't mean too I'm the dyamic
seeing like an American Horror Story season
or some [__] good boy and like a Zach Kinto
character a song let's go I'm not a
bubble of to cashing another lover
underneath those flashing light another
one of Ruth man this is so so unpleasant
po this a great song though this
seems like like a straight up PO up
song like a Jonas brother's One
Direction this is like a story of like
addiction and debauchery I got so good
at being untrue I got so good at telling
you what you want to hear it's the most
oppressed character well we knew that
uh angel dust was on drugs we understand
why it's pretty bold the way they're doing
this damn this is bold [__] man
story is going to end with Mead
from your poison poison I appreciate the
commitment to the harrowing side of it
yeah it's a little hard to watch so yeah
no it's it especially cuz it's animated
too why do you think he signed the contract
probably wanted fame or some [__] I need a
drink you look like [__] not possible just a
long Sho nothing new it's kind of interesting
see for a guy character too you know yeah
normally I feel like this would be a more
female Dr roll if you got a problem you're not
going to find the solution at the bottom of a
bottle I should know I've been looking there
a long time then where should I look in your
bedroom maybe maybe we can go look together
this is a very unique show man God damn you
can cut the ACT already it's never going to work
on me so all you're doing is making an ass out of
yourself with this fake [__] to me face one
more time mother you would be lucky to get a
chance to me you know how many people would kill
to have angel dust come on De M have fun being a
lonely piece of [__] whoa he looked really
upset it's just Angel you'll be fine I'm not
so sure I really messed up at the studio today and
he got it wasn't good okay they have masterfully
handled transitioning tones that look he'll come
back when he's ready I just don't want anything
to happen to him until then now if you'll excuse
me I'm going to go write 100 apology letters and
a lesson plan for tomorrow about Foundry all the
fainting Embrace that you know Angel does of the
lifestyle he lives is just all an escape he's
got no choice too yeah so I said you couldn't
afford me in a million after lives you got hey
baby be a doll and bring me another one coping
mechanisms this is sad Greg I think it's really
it's bold that the show would do this on their
fourth episode I know I know it's more like a
season 2 kind of [__] you get you know nice
try let's go classic barf fight that put something
in your drink you don't think I can tell if
someone spikes my drink I do this all the time oh
Jesus you think I asked for it I don't ask for any
of this [__] I didn't ask to be this way wow I
can handle myself really so much because I just
saw someone self-destructive exactly it seems like
you might need a bartender to talk to Classic you
think after how you treated me I'm going to open
up to you maybe I'd treat you better if you were
real let me tell you nobody in that hotel
cares who you are how famous haha so you
might as well just cut the a they care who
you want or anything it's not an act it's
who I need to be and this this is my escape
and survival mechanism where I can forget
about it all how much I hate everything this
a so film Noir yeah but with colors if I can
ruin myself enough in the process if I end up
broken I won't be his favorite toy anymore oh
that is heartbreaking I like hate this
Greg I was an Overlord once you know
really it was nice to have that power but when
you're dealing in Soul while ooh also being a
gambler the mistakes are pretty high and losing
a few hands can be more than a little dangerous
right you turn to anything to keep you AF
float even making deals yourself so I know
what it's liked oh yeah cuz we know regret the
choices made and no one you can't take it back
what a fascinating show so things look bad
and your backs against the W songs are such
a reward every time there's catharus to them
you're feeling filthy as a dive bar bathroom
stall oh my God can't face the world sober and
dop you think your life is wrecked well let me
just say you're correct except the reality you're
a loser baby a up little whiny [__] you're a
loser just like me my God affirm the realities
I needed this so bad cuz I was so sad just now
Yom but you got company yeah there was a time I
thought that no one could relate this person's
voice is Bomb it's Keith David Oh Yeah Yeahs
down straight Amen to that I sold my soul to
a psychopathic freak and you you think that makes
you unique what a layer light baby will Los it's
okay
honey damn got anti for gambling
got anti what a great animation
I got no hoes left to deflow i
s my soul to save my power I'm
trapped wow this being the two of their episode
is cool it's an ensemble show right now it's time
to Lose Yourself this is a very moving episode
play your card be who you are a loser just like
there he is singing oh I love that song [__]
stay down I'll deal with this time to be badass
whoa cool oh my God he's the coolest
character in the whole showat sucker
teamwork awesome I can handle myself baby wow
well that was something I didn't expect to
see like very Guardians of the Galaxy
right now it's exactly what I'm sing
yeah he he had like like three
bills a and baggie said to send
husk and this is the guy you got to
take orders from I know what a joke
right I'm so ever Charlie it's fine
I get it thanks for caring about me
a I think this is yours okay
Missy yeah said for forgive
me [__] like Maggie you read my mind we
finally came to a easy one to commit to
memory that was
awesome when we saw that it said 18 plus and all
the other episodes 16 plus I was like how could
it get raunchier really like how could how could
animation and then yeah this just made it like
it's dealing with really really effed up traumatic
like horrible things that was wild that they were
able to pull that off I I don't even know how
they did that I feel like usually with a with
shows that are special that are that start off as
so comedically heavy you don't get your your real
serious thing and till like a special episode like
a later season you know and totally the way they
have managed to I don't know how to expl it's
been like this like a like a little wave that
has gone into elements that get more serious over
time because it it doesn't feel like it's out of
this realm for the show to go there cuz that
seed has always been there like from the very
from the pilot you know not not episode one but
the pilot uh this whole idea we're talking about
reform and the way the Reformation is happening
is by uncovering who people really are underneath
the surface right because at with someone like
Charlie she has always seen that at the end of
the day they are souls and there are people under
before there was the darkness there was light and
that Darkness has clouded that light and who
that light is is who these people really are
and she wants to like unpack that so all this like
cliche trusting EX aren't going to be the trick
so it it is through form via of connection it is
through form of just being honest with yourself
and dealing with the current reality that's why
I love that loser song because it it is just them
affirming the truth and accepting that and being
okay with that and instead of trying to be like
no you're not don't do that don't think this it is
just about being like where you are right now and
that's okay yeah radical acceptance and practicing
that it's like if you've made the choices you've
made and you have to live somewhere you are living
right now what's the point in further judging that
and further punishing yourself when what the
choices you've made are already punishing you
enough yeah you know and I think that that it
it's like two different sides of the same coin
with the two of them as we're seeing the gambling
versus the sex working and like it um selling your
soul to somebody and not having power over your
your body your choices whatever it is just can't
believe that this show that started the way it
did was able to tonally shift so so uh seamlessly
because they painted such we've talked about in
previous episodes this world building we're just
in different Pockets right like it's not like this
felt like a different world this just felt like
a little different corner of Hell MH and we've
seen other corners of hell and my last the last
episode we watched remember my questions are like
what's going on with Lilith what's going on with
the um devil uh radio man what's going whatever
not one of my questions was like what's up with
angel dust and the bartender yeah and so I didn't
think that's what I gave a crap about as much and
then they were like oh here's why you should care
and I'm like oh you're right I do care now thank
you for telling me why I should care you know
it's not it's not where our minds were going
going into episode 4 and then they were just like
no this is what we want to do with episode 4 it
kind of reminds me this is such a weird one but
did you see The Last of Us you did CU you have
that sick shirt from it so I know that you watch
the show yeah um the episode where we go to Nick
offerman's character yeah and I didn't play the
video game obviously but it's like it's just such
a standalone episode moment that breaks off so
early on in the show that I'm kind of like whoa
that was ballsy and risky that that's what you
guys want to do and this kind of for different
reasons felt like that where this they're like
they're making this choice and they probably know
this means they could lose some of their audience
and they could gain the respect of the people who
stay even more because what a bold decision this
was that was wild that was a wild TV episode yeah
because this gets to uncomfortable terrain this
gets to Ser this is serious business right here
we're talking about like all kinds of levels of
abuse of power and ways that are very degrading
and dehum and dehumanizing and also play on
very realistic thing that's the thing is like
they they they as much as they're like oh it's
cool animation and they they do some things with
uh making them hellish characters still feels like
very real cuz at its emotional core the characters
the way they're uh I don't mean this in just in an
animation sense just the uh figuratively speaking
the illust the way they're Illustrated and the way
the Dynamics are Illustrated it's it's scary it's
intense because it feels like real you know and
uh and I I I respect it so much because there's
been all the episodes have been like we've been
saying I feel like there's like something deeper
here but I don't know if we're just going deeper
or if we're just supposed to accept that are we
thinking more into it than the show and then
you get to this you're like no this show has
100% been deeper this entire time and it I love
that it respects the audience enough to go far
past just being you know fun musical comedy and
go right to and do something like this to make
it more human like take a character who just was
kind of this one note joke and really make them
more human over time all of them were like all
these characters we've gotten to know everyone
at this hasman hotel so much better now yeah and
and with all different genres splic through in
to keep an engaging focus and then you get a
song like that which is like a a real it has
that like 80s pop song FLIR to it like a movie
moment but if it feels it was serious it it was
moving you're like watching The Vision like man
this is disturbing yeah I love your point going
back though about how we kept being like Oh
there's so many layers here but then you're
like is that are those accidental layers or those
layers just like me extrapolating from this like
but then they show us this and you know they've
planted every single one of those seeds they know
exactly what they're doing which I think is just
yeah it's it's unbelievable uh yeah this show has
my attention well there's no show like it no no
this show has my attention because as somebody I
know I started this in the pilot saying this I
watched 115 Plus shows every single year so to
get to really have my attention and be able to
be like I I've never seen anything like this and
I've never seen anything like this yeah well it's
like first it's like on the surface it it feels
like nostalgic in the way it's just drawn but
the way the way the world gets more fleshed out
not bad I was just drawn that way name movie
that's a she's a she's a God I know it a red
dress it's half animation half not frame
Roger R yeah he gave it away there I was
like well it's either Space Jam or who frame
Roger R so I'm that bad I was just drawn that
way anyway oh Betty what's peep poop boop beep
B peep oh my God her first of all that girl's
name is Betty Boop and the other person's name
you're trying to say is Little B peep who's the
girl who said it rabbit that was Jessica
Rabbit who said it I don't know I think
so I don't recall but uh yeah uh Beautiful
episode and great good musical oh and then
the last thing like uh the thing tooo you go
first no you go first no it's okay I already
forgot mine no cuz I [__] it up no no no
you just go uh I don't remember now here a
while oh I remember oh I remember I remember I
was worried at first in this episode because I
thought they were I didn't know if I was going
to enjoy their stance on sex workers like I
thought they were being judgmental the show it
for the first um part of this episode I didn't
know where they were going with like the fact
that they were um that like he was doing this
and it seemed like they the show was looking
down upon it but really what they were doing
was putting us in the perspective of um the the
princess and bringing us into like oh savior mode
and that was not where we needed to be this is
just like the reality of this guy's situation
yeah I mean it's like I I think obviously there
is that stereotype when it comes to sex workers
of yeah they're all just damaged people you
know it's not true right so that's what I was
thinking that they were showing but that's not
what was happening which I was glad about no
and it exp it actually exposes a commentary on
a different side of real world stuff you know
that is very tragic and and harming and harmful
and uh and and it actually works within genre of
because this is such a throwback vibe to like
you know the 30s to 50s of those old kind of
like Hollywood starlets who would be like abused
and used and and um tossed around and stuff so I
I think like it still works within the framew
framework of the genre that it riffs the the
time period that it really riffs on uh so yeah
I thought that was excellent man I I was moved
to Tears by the end that was really touching it
was really good really really good I'm stoked for
however many episodes we have left we got toast
just two two yeah so Roxy and I we watched five
today pilot one two three four five and then
we got just two to do when they are and they
drop at the same time yeah so did they release
these two at a time we don't know I have no idea
Hollywood weird release schedule anyway guys what
do you think about this episode is it one of your
f AV where you move to leave your thoughts down
below catch you for episode five and six later
dudes Chase Gardner Chase happy New Year Chase
Garder man boy if I know Chase and believe me
we know each other really well no one knows
Chase like you I know exactly what your New
Year's resolution is going to be for the year 2024
yes all right you are going to collect as many
gnomes as possible yes you need a hobby become
a gnome collector you need a niche because the
next person that ticks you off oh all right let's
say and if I know Chase he's very easily perturbed
by the slightest [__] that happens in public all
right let's say uh you're you know waiting in line
at your your nearest 7-Eleven and the person's
just taking [__] forever to check out you're
just like come on man I've been here for a while
seriously who brings change anymore yeah why is he
counting and giving exact change how big is your
coin jar at 711 swipe your credit card you have AB
wallet I I could see this is building up in you oh
and there it goes now you've made a mortal enemy
now you got to follow this person to their house
this person who owns a house who apparently pays
in change I know wild character right they just a
pen very very precise finances so they so then you
fall in her home and then what do you do with all
your known they wake up in the middle of the night
after you dingdong ditch them when they wake up
to a display of gnome every imaginable gnome out
in their front yard horrified staring up at them
it's the ultimate ultimate Challenge just to get
back yeah and if that doesn't work how scary would
that be that would be horrifying to come out and
just see like a bunch of inexplicable gnomes yeah
I thought about this for days yes it would be it
would be hor it would be worse than that Goosebump
there's like a bunch of them and they're alive
but I mean like I don't know even if they weren't
alive just like the thought and I don't know it's
like you wouldn't want to turn your back plus if
it doesn't work you could just grab one and Club
them over the head with it that always works this
chair makes me a very bendy person ooh is your
yoga chair it's your flexa throne I have been very
I have been stretching again that's good it's good
for you stretchy 2024 I need to get the Spitz back
John you do that could be your thing again you can
shoot it in portrait and put it on Tik Tok and be
like splits reactions I just my Instagram could
just be like I'm going to do the splits here
oh my God I'm going go to the store and do the
splits I'm G to go to here the splits such a funny
Instagram that would be really great I'm going to
church I'm going do the splits and the thing is
the more you grow that you know some [__] like
that would just take off for no reason it would
and thing is you would be able eventually as it
picks up to write off trip after vac I'm going
to do splits the Eiffel Tower I'm going to do my
splits in the leading Tower Pisa I'm going to do
my splits in the catacombs below Paris I'll do my
splits in an ancient Monastery I'm doing my splits
at the Make A Wish Foundation today with some sick
kids splits guy yeah cuz that's what the algorithm
favors it's just yeah pick a pick a lane I think
you just got to do to a public setting and just
don't announce it and just like I'm just going to
do like don't make a deal just that random dude
flash of the split just you it's just one guy if
I could just get to a point where I could like
how when I was really young where I could just
fall into it at a moment's notice just like fall
I used to be able to jump tuck my knees and then
fall into the split I was like so obsessed with
doing the splits so if I can get to that point
again where I'm just out in public and I and then
every like get the reaction from like bam right
off and then every like seventh or eighth one
you do a front split oh just to mix it up good
the front I'm trying really trying to get it okay
that's as I've gotten older the part of my body
that's gotten the more stiff I have clicking
shoulders oh I've have clicking shoulders and
I have really stiff hips so I've been stret Str
doing a lot of random hip stretches anyway chase
this is because of you steal this idea now have
a new Instagram page to work that a hilarious
Instagram you just got to get the right name got
to do the splits where two splits how two split
it's got to be something so simple it's stupid
like splits Greg or something Greg splitz G
Spitz spit spitzy
COA oh yeah funny do the splits Chase and then
I can find some other scammers do the exact same
thing we should collap we should do it we got to
meet him somewhere to do the splits and then yeah
yeah find somebody who does like splits and then
you guys can team up and then find someone who
do cartwheels to like do a cartwheel behind you
you do those like VR things that people do they C
around and and then you could do you there's so
many collab opportunities and they would all be
like 3C videos but you you could like grow like
a whole ass circus surrounding this a funny assd
scrip dud that would be really funny and it's
the perfect it's easy to do sort of it's it's
easy enough to do it's easy to capture it's quick
it's not messy it doesn't get the way of anything
everyone would be like this guy doesn't do any
work all he does is do the splits be like I'll
have you know I have to maintain I work very
hard to get to the point of doing this yeah
and it's something I've been maintaining from
a young I have to work really hard to make
sure I can still do the splits For You For Your
Entertainment just so I could walk into Denny's
and do the and I get a free moons over my hammy
dude the perks man the perks thanks buddy love
you